Second question today, Hey David, wouldn't
free college and healthcare drastically, kneecap
military enlistment since lots of people join
the military to get those things.
So there's two parts here.
Question one is whether that would happen.
Question two is whether it's a bad thing.
It is true.
There are lots of people who go into the military
in the United States because they can't afford
to go to college or they are not cut out for
college and the military is one of the most
direct paths to earning a steady paycheck
from a reliable employer.
There are other financial reasons and certainly
healthcare is another thing that the military
provides.
There are also arguments which say that if
you improve education and healthcare and access
to them, you would end up with more people
enlisting because they know they can always
go back to getting an education and they might
feel less pressured to do it right away because
they know that it's always there waiting for
them in some sound sense, but I believe that
that is effectively not the right way to approach
the question.
Number one.
Fortunately for us, we have more than enough
people in our military and a significantly
bigger than necessary military force, so the
military not having enough recruits because
people can go to college or have healthcare
is not a realistic concern.
Number two, let's go even further though.
People who join the military for economic
necessity.
I don't believe are the people that I would
prefer be in the military if we don't have
a draft, which we don't.
I want the people in the military to be people
who want to be in the military, not people
who have no interest in it but have no money
for education or healthcare and they join
out of desperation.
I don't think that that's good for the military.
This is why the recruiting that the military
does in poor areas, going to high schools
where the appeal is simply economic is so
predatory and I will even go further than
that.
If we had universal healthcare, you might
break the bottleneck that is the overloaded
VA hospital and improve treatment for veterans
by clearing out the VA facilities a little
bit by allowing people to go elsewhere.
Education can make it so that when veterans
come back from serving, they have more options
for jobs when they come back and they will
be a better integrated into society as opposed
to often ending up concentrated in certain
fields.
One other thing, tons of young people aren't
even eligible to enlist because of health
issues, including obesity, which is an epidemic
in the United States.
Better educated people are less likely to
be obese.
Overall healthier people with access to healthcare
are less likely to be obese.
It is an interesting proposition that by providing
education and healthcare to people, you will
reduce obesity and increase the number of
people that are medically eligible to join
the military and actually grow the number
of people that are enlisting.
It's something to think about.
So I think that whenever we, we see something
like, Oh, hold on.
Uh, if people no longer need to join the military
because they be for healthcare or economic
reasons, the military will be hurt.
Well, let's first figure out whether that's
true.
And secondly, let's figure out whether it's
actually hurt if different people or fewer
people are enlisting.
I think in this case the answer seems to be
the exact opposite.